and finally for this week for me
we got to talk even more unfortunately
about the turning point usa conference
because there's one last thing from that
that i want to discuss that is truly
terrifying and that is madison cawthorne
during his speech
started talking about civil war
and how if we have another civil war
which he swears he doesn't want but if
we have one
man conservatives are totally gonna win
it
here's what he says
we patriotic americans because
republicans hold the monopoly on
patriotism
we're born for such a time as this we're
going to face some dark times as a
nation i genuinely believe that i think
we have an opportunity in the next four
to six years to prevent kinetic force
countrymen on countrymen
from ever meeting
although i have no doubt we would be
victorious if that would ever happen but
remember that that would be so immoral
and wrong if we said hey you know what
let's kick off a civil war
and then we'll just go ahead and go to
that point
it's time for us to stop being sheep and
stand up and be lions the radical left
should be terrified of who we are the
radical left should be terrified of what
we are going to do
oh we are
we absolutely are
because we've seen what you do
we've seen what your kind does
they storm the capital
they assault police officers while
storming the capitol
they call in death threats
to secretaries of state because they
don't like the election results of that
state
they call in so many death threats to
certain members of congress that they've
had to undergo special training
on how to handle these things
they issue racist and bigoted threats to
them
on the floor of the house of
representatives do i need to go on or do
you get the picture here yeah
that's what terrifies us
it terrifies us that this is becoming
normalized and it's becoming normalized
by people like madison cawthorn himself
also in his little speech there
he encouraged people to drop out of
college
told young conservatives if you're not
going to be a doctor lawyer engineer
just drop out it's a scam he said
he dropped out and he turned out just
fine
yeah so fine by the way
that he is running for congress in a
different district next year
because his current district is turning
blue and he knows he can't win so he has
to switch over to a different one in
order to you know keep his job that he
clearly
is not qualified or even rational enough
to be holding
before i go today
i want to take another moment here to
thank david to thank pat
thank everybody
with the david pakman show for giving me
this opportunity the week of christmas
to fill in
to be here with you i thank everybody
who tuned into this and of course if
you've enjoyed me
and even if not you should probably
still do this you can subscribe to my
youtube channels youtube.com slash the
ring of fire and youtube.com fair and
balanced
you can catch me every week on the ring
of fire podcast
rofpodcast.com
twitter facebook and instagram at farron
balanced i hope everyone has a wonderful
holiday weekend whether you celebrate or
not take some time enjoy it have some
good food relax
and wait for the new year to begin i'm
farin cousins and for david pakman thank
you for watching